why is this an important story to tell
this is the story of our time in that
we've inherited this incredible new
technology there's something going on
inside the government that's really
wrong and I can't ignore it I feel like
this is an important story to tell
because it's something that's happening
in real time it's not a historical event
now we're still reflecting on it's
something that's still immediately
affecting the way our lives are lived
today think of it as a Google search
except instead of searching only what
people in public we're also looking at
everything they don't yeah but which
people the whole kingdom is no way IOC
isn't a human right anymore it's a
privilege the concept of privacy is it a
concept now or is it something that is
real anymore like is privacy even
something that any of us have the
ability to attain house is food I've had
lots of conversations with people who
have seen the film and they're like it
made me want to get rid of all my
technology and move and run into the
woods I'm like well even now a
technology there's drones and their
satellites so even these indigenous
communities who are living in the middle
of the Amazon forest are still being
monitored we have the right we have the
privilege to hold our government
accountable not everyone everywhere has
that privilege we're slashing out no I'm
not lashing out I'm questioning our
government the decisions that we make
now us as a generation are going to
cascade and have rippling effects moving
in the future for what this technology
is to us
the NSA is really tracking every cell
phone in the world I think it's really
good that we're just talking about it
and thinking about it